قبل اقل من عام بدات روسيا عمليتها
العسكريه بدخول اقليم دمباز من الشرق فما
هي ابرز محطات العمليه الروسيه شرقي
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه وصلت التقدم في
مارس واقتربت من السيطره على اول مدينه
اوكرانيه كبيره شمال شرقي البلاد وهي كمان
نشاهد هنا حركات انتصار وصف بالاستراتيجيه
تحقق في شهر مايو بالسيطره على ماريوبل
المطله على بحر از اوف بعد صمود نحو جندي
اوكرانيه داخل مصنع ايف ستايل للصلب
لحوالي الشهر بعد السيطره الروسيه على
ماريو بيل ومدن عده في اقليم جمباز بقيت
على الجانب الاخر في الشرق مدينه
حينها في الثامن والعشرين من مايو تمكنت
القوات المواليه لروسيا من السيطره على
مدينه ليمان مركز مهم بتاعك الحديديه في
منطقه دونياس كما هو معروف في يونيو
الماضي اعلن حاكم لو جانسك سيطرت القوات
الروسيه على مدينه سيفرودونياسك
الاستراتيجيه في الثالث من يوليو وبعد
احكام السيطره على سيفردونيس كواليس اعلنت
القوات الروسيه السيطره على منطقه لوجاست
فيما تبقى امامها منطقه دونياس لاحكام
قبضتها على اقليم دومباز باكمله انذاك كما
نذكر شهر سبتمبر شهد مشاهدينا تقدما
اوكرانيا شرقي مع السعاده بلدات رئيسيه
بينها ايسيوم في ديسمبر وبدايه العام
الجديد تتركز الجهود الروسيه على مدينتي
سيفرياس وباخمه المجاورتين
وصوليدار المجاوره هي الطريقه الاقرب
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف